[موسيقى]
خوف يدفع بالالاف نحو الشوارع في اسرائيل
تستوحي هذه الفتيات شخصيات الاماء من
روايات امريكيه احداث خياليه في الولايات
المتحده بعد سيطره اليمين المتطرفي على
مفاصل الحكم يتحول الجميع في الروايه الى
خدم للمشروع الايديولوجي المتطرف هذا ما
يخشاه هؤلاء في شوارع تل ابيب والقدس كما
يقولون
[موسيقى]
يرى عشره الاف المحتاجين هنا ان تعديلات
نتنياه القضائيه هي جزء من كابوس سيغير
شكل البلاد تلك تعديلات يقول معرضها انها
تمكن اليمين من السيطره بشكل دكتاتوري على
كل شيء ينقسم الشارع السياسي في اسرائيل
يمينا تمسك بالتعديلات من رئيس الوزراء
واعضاء الائتلاف الحاكم في مقدمتهم لتمار
بن جفيرس مودريتش يقولون انها خطه للاصلاح
القضائي يسارا رفض للتعديلات من رئيس
الحكومه السابق وحلفائه في الوسط واليسار
وفي مقدمتهم وزير الدفاع السابق بنجانتس
يقولون انها بدايه النهايه للديمقراطيه
بين الطرفين شد وجذب يرتكز على قواعده
ايديولوجيه بدرجه اساسيه تدخل معركه عبد
الاصابع مرحله حساسه تزيد من الازمه دعوات
الاضرابات التي شملت قطاعات عده تعلن
السفارات الاسرائيليه التوقف عن العمل
وينعكس الامر نفسه على القطاع الطبي
وقطاعي النقل البحري والجوي والجامعات
ومراكز التسوق البنوك الكبرى اعلن ميناء
اسدود وحيثا التوقف عن العمل فعلى الامر
نفسه مطار بنغوريون فتوقفت حركه الطيران
اغلقت مراكز تسوق كبرى ابوابها وكذلك فعل
بل كان رئيسيا ستتوقف الحركه في اسرائيل
هكذا هدد رئيس الاتحاد العام لنقابات
العمال الاستدروت ويبدو انه فعل كل هذه
الاضرابات اثرت بشكل مباشر في سعر صرف
الشيك المقابل الدولار انخفضت العمله
الاسرائيليه لادنى مستوى لها منذ ثلاثه
اعوام هكذا تدخل اسرائيل نفقا مظلما يخيم
على سير الحياه مع لجوء الجميع الى الشارع
تنكشف صوره اخرى للدوله العبريه